the committee will come to order
apologize for the delay but we were in a
caucus that's still going on actually
but I'm very pleased to welcome
Secretary Clark and his colleagues today
and the purpose of the hearing is to
assess the executive branch proposal for
3.1 billion sale dollar sale of 315 m1a2
tanks and other military equipment
services to Saudi Arabia the equipment
is some of the most sophisticated in the
United States military arsenal the m1a2
tank is believed to be second to none in
the armoured arsenals of the world some
and I count myself among them I deeply
convinced we should be very wary of
shoving more and more of our
sophisticated equipment into the that
region of the world it is clear that a
continuing arms race in the Middle East
is to nobodies benefit one is only to
look at the recent iran-iraq war which
involved the use by both sides of highly
sophisticated remarkably lethal hardware
to understand the weapons of destruction
are used all too frequently for their
intended purpose the tens of thousands
of needless dead in the battlefields of
Iran and Iraq attest to that
as do the American fatalities and
casualties sustained in our attempt to
maintain commerce in a combat zone
loaded with remarkably effective weapon
rate we had helped provide I hope we
will learn that attention is being paid
that this proposed sale essential vital
matters and the possible effect upon
regional stability whether it would
contribute to an arms race whether it
would contribute to the possibility of
further conflict in that tumultuous
region I hope we will not discover that
this is a sale driven primarily by the
promise of financial gain with
insufficient truth God for the perils
which may be involved my own view is
always been that we should be very very
restrained in sending into developing
parts of the world developing nations
lethal military
equipment of a sophisticated nature and
I have some skepticism about this sale I
would be very glad to hear for mr. Clark
and his associates and I would add at
some point in the course of these
proceedings we'll have to wrap up or be
at least be interrupted because we will
have to have an executive meeting to
pass out some nominations mr. Clark very
good mr. chairman thank you for this
opportunity to continue our
consultations on this sale which we have
been engaged in for the last several
months I'd like if I may to enter into
the record three papers first a fact
sheet entitled proposed sale of the m1a2
tank to Saudi Arabia secondly a
background paper entitled background
information sale of Abrams tanks to
Saudi Arabia and third with your
permission sir my my testimony which I
prefer just to summarize attack thank
you full text related the record as if
read Thank You mr. chairman as you know
for many years we have worked closely
with the Saudi government in the United
States Army Defense Department have
worked very closely with the Saudi
military to prudently plan the
modernization of their Armed Forces as a
result of of that planning the Saudis
have determined that they need a new
tank they have a very small army but
nonetheless they have a need as all
nations do to have a modern force and a
modern army currently excuse me for
interrupting I just can't resist it why
should all nations have a modern army
well sir all nations that are in
neighborhoods where their neighbors have
modern armies in neighborhoods where
there have been history and where there
has been a history of war and conflict
and I think to deter future attack to
maintain stability Saudi Arabia just
like the United States feels it needs an
army the Saudis have as a result of
several years of examination and
planning determined that the best size
force for them to add is is 315 US m1
tanks and so they've asked us for this
sale in examining their request we've
asked ourselves four questions first
is it militarily necessary currently
their tank forests the bulk of their
tank force consists of very old French
AMX 30 tanks these are aging tanks they
are hard to maintain some of them have
been put out of service the Saudis have
as I said a small army they need the
ability to deter attack they are a
sufficiently small country in terms of
population that they cannot really pose
an offensive threat but as prudent
planners they need to look at future
threats and in doing so they look at all
azimuth surround their their borders and
see a long history of conflict in the
region a long history of countries
threatening the use of military force
and they believe they need a deterrent
capability a small capability that their
small army would be able to man in
looking at the threats they have to
judge not just
current intentions of their neighbors
but also current capabilities of their
neighbors and future capabilities these
tanks which will last them twenty to
thirty years will not begin to arrive in
Saudi Arabia for several years and so
they're looking out well into the next
century in terms of their military
requirements so based on what we believe
and what they believe is prudent
military planning they need for a
deterrent capability for a small army we
think that there is military
justification for this sale the second
question we always ask ourselves is is
there political justification for this
sale are the foreign policies of the
country consonant with ours are they a
force for peace are they a force for
stability in the region and I think the
answer is definitely in the affirmative
if we look at three sub regions in the
area
the Saudis policies have been supportive
of our own first in South Asia Saudi
Arabia has worked closely with us in
support of Pakistan and Afghanistan
secondly in the Persian Gulf the Saudis
have been the force for stability I know
it in particular their assistance to us
in the reef lagging episode in the
spring and summer of 1987 in the Persian
Gulf and thirdly in the in the Middle
East I point to their constructive role
in Lebanon including their recent
sponsorship of the Parliament meeting in
Saudi Arabia their influential role in
bringing Egypt back into the Arab fold
after it had been kicked out for signing
the Camp David Accords the
our influence in moderating the position
of the PLO and their constructive role
in moderating the Arab attitude toward
the peace process as demonstrated by the
Fahad plan and the Fez conference the
third question we asked ourselves with
regard to armed cells in the Middle East
is what would the effect of this armed
sale be on the security of Israel you
know mr. chairman that we have a pledged
Israel that we will maintain their
qualitative military edge over any
conceivable alliance of nations arrayed
against them and we have looked at what
these tanks could mean to that Arab
Israeli military balance I've asked the
intelligence community to make a
judgment on the balance the effect on
the balance the intelligence community
has determined and we concur both in the
State Department and the Defense
Department that these tanks do not
contribute to a deterioration of
Israel's qualitative military edge after
asking ourselves these three questions
and only after asking ourselves these
questions and getting affirmative
replies we then do look at the fourth
question which is the economic benefit
the economic benefit is as you've
suggested substantial it involves a
three billion dollar cash sale it
provides 50 thousand man years of
employment in the United States and a
direct monetary benefit to the United
States government approximately six
hundred million dollars so the wrap-up
on military grounds on political grounds
on consideration of Israel's security
requirements and finally on economic
grounds we believe that this sale is
justified
and it's part of our continuing
long-term relationship political and
military relationship with a peaceful
and friendly country a relationship
going back 50 years mr. Chairman I have
with me today deputy assistant secretary
Jeanine from the Middle East Bureau and
state deputy assistant secretary Hughes
from the Pentagon and Colonel Bo
Eldridge of the United States Army
there's an expert on armor and tanks
we'd be glad to take your questions on
any aspect of the sale
thank you very much for a very clear
testimony I want to thank you for your
appearance the other day in the closed
session of the committee where we had I
think a good exchange
I guess my own view starts out from the
sort that no weapons na use unless
there's a man who pulls the trigger
makes it work I realized that the human
beings are at fault that Wars not the
machines of the warfare but I can't help
but think that when we distribute 300
tanks when one does how many human
beings will be killed by those tanks
before they've served their purpose if
any but I think that's why I have an
inherent prejudice against giving
sophisticated weapons around the world I
think I'm correct in saying that the
Soviets that we enjoy the distinction of
being the two leaders in distributing
weapons around the world and I'd like to
press this point a little bit and asking
you what you believe is a threat that
the Saudi Saudis face in their region
where the enemies now mr. chairman it's
a threat that is potential and not
necessarily current I don't think any of
us believe that there is a opposing army
about to march against Saudi Arabia
today but Saudi Arabia is a very
attractive target for some it's a very
wealthy nation it's a nation with very
few people to defend very long borders
and we've seen going back only a few
years rather recently a threat to that
part of the region posed by Iran I can
recall briefing members of this
committee only two years ago that it
looked like a major Iranian breakthrough
would take place near the Iraqi Kuwaiti
border and that if that did happen and
if the Iraqi army crumbled as looked
looked possible at some points during
the war that Iran could sweep through
Kuwait and into Saudi Arabia so there
has been a recent threat in the past
there have been threats armed from
almost every direction going back over
the last 40 years and I think a prudent
Saudi military planner must look out to
the next 20 or 30 years the lifetime of
this of this tank and think that it
would be possible again for threats to
come in this region the reason they're
buying this this tank is so that they
would have deterrence that would raise
the cost of any invader in the future a
force this small can't really be used in
an offensive way in the neighborhood
that Saudi Arabia is in most countries
in the region have much larger forces
but we think they could be able to deter
an attack and raise the cost to a
potential invader in the future but then
it's your view that we should put
weapons in an area when the danger is
potential not real in other words you're
talking about potential adversaries not
actual adversaries yes sir I think it's
often too late after a an adversary has
already materialized and is threatening
a country to deploy weapons such as this
kind it will take many many years for
the Saudis to learn how to operate these
tanks and to integrate them into
therefore
structure if we were only to send them
after a threat materialized they would
not be able to use them effectively
against that threat what percentage of
the PLO operating budget is finished by
Saudi Arabia in your view sir I don't
have a figure on on the PLO budget I'm
not sure that we dis roughly is
horseback yesterday
I'm sorry sir I'd LA I I just don't know
what it's mr. chairman let us let us
take that question and see if that
information is available to us it may be
available to us on the classified basis
but we'll try to find the answer and get
it back to you thank you my recollection
is that it's about more than half but
does that sound wrong to you I have no
idea so I did sir if I could ask Deputy
Assistant Secretary Hughes to expand a
little on my comments about the threat
thank you mr. Hughes Thank You mr.
chairman perhaps a word or two about
Saudi armored doctrine and disposition
of forces would help allay your concerns
about possible offensive character first
of all the Saudi military consists of
four mechanized brigades and two armored
brigades can compose now of about 15,000
men who defend a country the size of the
US east of the Mississippi River their
armored doctrine is defensive we know
because we have the US Army has worked
with them over the years to develop
their military force and their doctrine
we train them we know how they train how
they go about their work what their
objectives are and their deployment is
to disperse these six units all around
the periphery of the entire country also
they do not have the logistic support
and mechanism which would allow them to
mass their forces to enable them to
attack any in any of their neighbors in
any direction based on all of these
factors were convinced indeed that this
is a defensive force and that these
tanks serve a legitimate deterrent and
defensive purpose
has this meant that there's a quid pro
quo for these weapons these tanks we've
had to finish other weapon systems to
other neighbors of Saudi Arabia to
balance this force no mr. chairman we we
have not we don't think this this sale
of 315 tanks poses an additional threat
to any friendly nation and does not
require us to to specifically compensate
any nation in the region with weapons or
other devices to to deal with these
tanks we don't think these tanks pose an
offensive threat to anybody have you
have received any protest of any of its
neighbors with regard to this weapon
sale we have not received any formal
protest from any country about this
weapon so we received an informal focus
mr. chairman as you as you know the the
traditional attitude of the State of
Israel toward arms sales to Arab
countries who have not yet signed a
peace treaty with them is one of
formally opposing such sales and we have
had discussions with the Israeli
government at all levels about this sale
and they have made that that standard
statement but I I don't I don't think
that the Israelis believe that this this
tank sale poses a threat to them and I
would I would not want to be put in the
situation where I am a spokesman for
Israel about this sale I would think
that we should let them speak for
themselves and they have I agree with
you they have informally and vigorously
what why did Saudi Arabia participate in
the recent effort by Arab and other
nations to deny Israel's credentials at
the UN I must apologize sir someone was
whispering in my ear and I know my
question was why did Saudi Arabia
participate in the recent effort by the
various Arab nations to deny Israel's
credentials to be
there was a fairly interesting state of
play at the UN this year it was our
understanding early on that there was
not going to be a test of the Israeli
credentials this year and we were quite
happy about that and we made
representations throughout the region to
encourage a variety of governments to
maintain that position it was at a point
when some Iranian moves were made as
well as a few of the of the more radical
groups to try to push that and embarrass
some of the Arab governments that the
that that position began to change we
weren't very happy with that at all and
we made that quite clear that we think
this is indeed a change that the Arab
governments can make these are the
Israel that in fact supports the peace
process and in fact moves the whole
Middle East attitude in the direction
that things have gone in the last couple
of years and so we would we're going to
continue to work on on that one in the
coming year did we ask the Saudis not to
vote against Israel in this manner we
made presentations to all of the
governments that we had good relations
with including the Saudis and did we
succeed in persuading any of them no if
you know the vote we didn't succeed and
don't recall the vote no it was it was
pretty much an Arab League the unanimous
Arab League move Egypt of course did not
support that could you comment on
reports the administration concluded an
agreement to loan war materiel to Israel
in order to counter the Israeli
opposition to the proposed sale yeah yes
mr. chairman about five years ago we
formed an organization with Israel to
coordinate our military activities that
organization is known as the joint
political military group and I'm the
American chairman of that organization
about a year into the organization's
existence we negotiated a memorandum of
understanding with Israel on pre
positioning and host nation support and
as a result of that agreement we have
built a number of bunkers in Israel to
pre position American
supplies and some of those supplies have
already been stationed in the country
for about two years now as part of that
negotiation the Israeli government asked
us to in the future negotiate a second
agreement or to modify the agreement to
allow a secondary stockpile similar to
the ones that we have in Korea and
Thailand a stockpile to which the
Israeli army could have access in an
emergency we agreed at the time to take
that under advisement in the future but
to proceed first with a US only
stockpile the Israelis have recently
come back to us and reminded us of our
earlier pledge and we are taking that
pledge to look again at a second
agreement such as the Korean and time
models we're taking that under
consideration that request but that is
part of our overall contribution to the
security of Israel and to joint US
military activity with Israel there's
nothing specific about what we give
Israel to compensate for the Saudi tanks
the sow the tanks really don't pose an
offensive threat against Israel the
Israelis have enough capability now that
they have a qualitative military edge
against any conceivable combination of
Arab forces so yes we are proceeding as
we have been to the last five years
with pre positioning in Israel but what
we're pre positioning there is not pre
positioning designed to counterbalance
the Saudi tanks or any specific threat
mr. coisas has been done at this time
well it's being it's been as I say it's
been negotiated over the course of the
last five years and it's been an active
Israeli desire throughout that time
they accepted our proposition that it's
better to get us pre positioning done
first negotiate a simple agreement first
build the bunkers start the program and
then come back to the issue of a
dual-use stockpile such as we have with
Thailand and with Korea will the tanks
be available for the United States use
in the event of a crisis the United
States if it asked for them I'm sure
would depending on the circumstances the
Saudis could favorably respond there's
nothing specific in the agreement that
requires the southeast to give us the
tanks in the emergency but I think their
record of performance in 1987 shows when
there was a crisis in the region and
American military forces did have to go
in shows that they they favorably
consider our requests we in 1987 during
the reef flagging exercise in the Gulf
made on the order of 20 specific
requests for assistance to our military
forces and all of those were favorably
responded to we can provide a classified
summary of that that episode to the
committee thank you how would the tanks
difference of our own you from those
used by the United States chairman the
tank is an m1 a to the United States
will begin making that tank for itself
in the near future there are some five
or six or perhaps a few less than that
differences between the m1a2 that will
be in our own inventory and this export
version we can I think will have to
provide the differences between the two
tanks in a classified note but there are
some differences we would appreciate
that what's the timetable for delivery
let me ask Colonel Eldridge to address
that the first units equipped in the
u.s. inventory will be in the third
quarter in fiscal year 93 the first
delivery to the Saudis would be in the
second quarter of fiscal year 94 and the
deliveries will take three years once
they begin right thank you very much
senator Krantz to this point thank you
very much mr. chairman
I had quite a few questions one to ask
but I'm swamped by last-minute
activities of the session so I will not
be able to ask them I will submit I
believe some questions in writing and
I'd appreciate responses I just want to
make a very brief statement I apologize
for interrupting and I wish I could've
heard more of your testimony and talk
with you who are with us today at
greater length the administration has
gone to great lengths to consult with
Congress and the week leading up to the
announcement of the sale I want to
convey to a sister secretary Clarke my
appreciation for the forthcoming manner
in which the administration have dealt
with Congress on this matter that has
not always been the case in such matters
and I appreciate it at this time there's
been much discussion about the 315 m1a2
tanks the Saudis would like to buy from
us will the tanks have depleted uranium
ammunition or not depleted uranium
ammunition the most advanced electronic
components are not the answers are not
clear to me to those questions I'm
deeply concerned that in focusing on the
nuts and bolts of the sale we are
forgetting our most vital interests in
the region far more important than the
matter of exactly what equipment those
planes have u.s. arms sales to the
Saudis have over time totaled 50 billion
dollars why are we selling more arms to
a nation that have consistently worked
against our basic foreign policy
objectives in the Middle East I think
that's the main question yes the Saudi
Kingdom has taken a helpful role I grant
that in mediating between the
various Lebanese factions and we hope
that these efforts can lay the
groundwork for political reconciliation
in that war-torn nation but have the
Saudis demonstrated any signs of support
for American efforts in the arab-israeli
peace process we often hear of their
support for the Fahd and fez plans but
these embody proposals that are
completely unacceptable from our point
of view they have clearly rejected the
latest proposals for elections on the
West Bank
they provided no assistance on that
initiative in what way have the Saudis
helped in the war against terrorism what
are their egregious egregious human
rights violations it's always called me
that we deem moderate a nation that is
still in a state of war declared war
with one of our very closest allies
Israel the Saudis continued to try to
throw Israel out of the UN as recently
as last month they persisted maintaining
an economic boycott of Israel they
attempt to bully other nations into
doing likewise finally reports have been
circulating in the press that this tank
sale is a precursor to a much larger
sale that the administration is
considering to upgrade the Saudis aging
fleet of f50 f5s I hope this is not the
case as as a parent I have a lot of
questions about this I'll be looking for
the answer to them I apologize for my
inability directly ask those questions
at this time thank you very very much
mr. Mack chairman if I could I think I
can offer some brief answers to descend
the Cranston to some of his specific
questions just in very quickly will the
tanks have depleted uranium ammunition
no sir they will not yeah they will not
have depleted uranium ammunition as to
the advanced electronics in them as I
said to the Chairman will provide a
summary of what the differences are
between the US Army version of this tank
and the version going to Saudi Arabia
the 50 billion dollars
of sales to Saudi Arabia
I think hide the fact that over the
course of the period since 1953 when we
began a military relationship the vast
majority of what we sold technically
under the law as foreign military sales
was basically infrastructure and if I
can just quickly summary summarize the
types of items that make up that fifty
billion dollars since 1953 through this
year of that forty eight point two
billion only eleven percent was for
weapons
thirty percent was for logistics nine
percent for command control 2.3 percent
for training thirty two percent for
construction and design of military
bases because essentially when we began
this effort they had no military basing
structure so of the forty eight billion
dollars only eleven percent has been for
arms and if you look at the last decade
when we've sold twenty three billion
dollars worth of foreign military sales
cases to Saudi Arabia less nine point
one percent has been has been for arms
do the Saudis cooperate with us in our
war against terrorism yes they do we
have very substantial and very
cooperative programs with the Saudis in
the area of anti terrorism and again
most of the details of that have to
remain classified but we can try to
summarize them in a classified statement
as the administration made a decision
about an f5 replacement aircraft sale
and is this sale a precursor for that
the answer is that the administration
has made no decision and has not been
formally asked by the Saudis about an f5
replacement aircraft we know the Saudis
are interested eventually in replacing
the f5 we don't know when they plan to
do that they haven't told us that they
have asked us in some general
about us aircraft that we have entered
into no negotiation about the follow-on
aircraft and this sale the tanks stands
entirely separate and alone from that we
will try when we issue the annual Javits
report at the end of January to provide
a further update about the status of
Saudi considerations on their f5
replacement as we know it at that time
maybe I can ask Skippy neem to address
the your comments senator on the peace
process commander control include the
AWACS plane yes sir there we we don't
consider the AWACS a weapon it doesn't
it's not capable of firing anything
thank you
sir I'd just like to comment briefly on
some of your remarks about the Saudi
attitude toward peace I think we feel
very strongly that the Saudis have been
in fact an influence for moderation they
have not
for example rejected the current
proposals and current discussions that
are going on about elections on the West
Bank they certainly have some views that
they've expressed and these are not
always in accordance with our own but in
terms of the influence in terms of their
conversations with other moderate
governments with the PLO they have been
trying to exert an influence to
encourage the PLO and other moderate
elements in the Palestinian community to
stay engaged and work and talk they have
said over and over that they feel that
the solution to the arab-israeli problem
has to be through peaceful means they
have of course advocated international
conference which is the standard Arab
position which we have not agreed but
nevertheless the Saudi government art is
committed to pursuing a settlement of
the dispute peacefully and we have
looked to them a variety of times over
the last several months to weigh in use
their influence help us get over some
difficult points and they've done so and
we'd like to have more you mentioned the
UN vote and so did senator Pell earlier
and I admit
and said at that point it was not at all
to the satisfaction of United States
government that the Arab governments had
taken that position this year we thought
quite frankly it was going to go the
opposite direction this year and we're
going to work very hard on that in the
coming years thank you very much thank
you very much senator crasus in the bud
Thank You mr. chairman I apologize
gentlemen for being late and I was just
being briefed by staff as to what has
been asked and I'll try not to repeat
the questions and obviously if I repeat
a question it's already been asked I
just let me know and I'll read the
answer in the record let me ask you
about something that may or may not have
been asked but is not directly have to
do with the with the sale but in my view
has to do with the total balance in the
region from the United States
perspective how serious is the problem
of missile sales not tank South missile
sales such as the CSS to sale by China
to the Saudis and to other nations in
the region so that we've we've been up
here several times this year testifying
about missile sales in the Middle East
we think they are a very destabilizing
element in the military balance the most
destabilizing missiles I think in the
region are those of Syria and Iraq and
Iran
I would certainly add the CSS 2's in
Saudi Arabia to that list I think the
the reason we believe the Syrian and the
Iraqi and the Iranian missiles are are
the real problem is that those three
countries all have chemical weapons
programs they therefore have the
potential someday to put chemical
weapons on top of those missiles also
both Iraq and Iran have used their
missiles in in the recent war and used
them against civilian targets so we have
tried through a number of ways which
we've outlined to this committee
to stop the spread of missiles in the
Middle East I think we've had some
successes but it is a major problem how
does that combine with the tank sale
effect Saudis offensive capability well
we don't think the Saudis have an
offensive capability with regard to the
tanks if you look at the nations on
their periphery they are vastly
outnumbered in armored forces and ground
forces in general they have a very small
army an army which has to cover a very
large amount of territory we don't think
they really pose an offensive military
threat to anyone now clearly the CSS
twos do pose an offensive threat well
why do they have them they have them
because they saw missiles being used by
Iran against Arab countries against Arab
cities during their around Iraq war they
were in Saudi Arabia within range of
missiles fired from Iran they were
potentially in a war situation with Iran
and they needed they thought some
deterrence against Iranian missiles we
disagree with their decision to buy the
css-2 to achieve that deterrence we've
made that very clear at very high levels
doesn't in fact achieve deterrence
whether we like it or not
is it a deterrent weapon for them well
the trouble with deterrence as you never
know if it's working or if the opponent
isn't attacking you for some other
reason but it's certainly the case that
that should Iran fire missiles at Saudi
Arabia in the future they would have to
take into consideration the possibility
that Saudi Arabia can now strike back
with ballistic missiles sir I just might
add and that particular time frame which
assistant Secretary's talking about
correctly or wrongly the Saudis were
reading a lot of commentary that in fact
the Iranian population was demoralized
by the Iraqi use of missiles so they
concluded that in effect there was a
deterrence well we have a clear policy
in opposition to the sale of missiles in
that region and how is it to be read
that what sanction of any other than are
suggesting that please don't please
don't buy missiles you good old folks
because we think they're bad what kind
of message is a send that we have such a
clear policy the president and others
have been talking about how bad it is
they go ahead and purchase them and we
say by the way how about some tanks to
go along with it how what does that do
the senator to be fair the United States
opposition to ballistic missile
proliferation began in late 1986 it
became a formal US government position
in 1987 with the creation of the missile
technology control regime this sale
actually predates those two events so I
think what we have said to the Saudis
about our missile policy we said after
they bought the css-2 is that what
difference does it make well I think it
makes some difference if we had said to
them please don't do this and they went
ahead and did it that would be one thing
what we have here is a case of them
having done it and are then going to
them and saying we wish you hadn't I
think there was any doubt about our
policy clearly we we ratcheted up our
concern but our concern existed long
before 1986 and was known our concern
was known I doubt whether there was a
single Saudi who thought that the United
States thought it was a good idea for
them to purchase those missiles
the senator again to be fair I think the
Saudis many of the Saudis in in their
leadership were quite taken or struck by
the vehement of the American reaction
when we found out that they have the CSS
- you do acknowledge that there is a a
potential for arming the CSS - with a
biological or chemical warhead is that
right well we don't know that we don't
know you said that no I said that the
Iranian the Iraqi and the Syrian
missiles could be so armed we we have a
pledge at the highest levels from the
Saudi government that they will not put
chemical warhead or a nuclear warhead on
that missile I said potential it has a
physical potential doesn't it I don't I
don't know that the Chinese who made the
missile have done that most missiles you
can for the chemical warhead on I don't
know if you could do it with the CSS -
in any of your experts with you have a
moment's doubt that you can why do I do
this is truth in selling time I I have
some doubts it was designed as a
long-range nuclear missile it was
designed by the Chinese to attack the
Soviet Union with a very large nuclear
bomb and given the very long range and
the beta angle of reentry and the
ablative effects of reentry
from that very high altitude because
it's a long-range missile it is possible
that it might be a very tough
engineering problem to put the chemical
warhead on top of it in any event we
have the the promise of the Saudi
Arabian government that they will not do
so and from all information we have
they have abided by that promise where
did the Saudis intend to base these
tanks we've had some discussions with
the Saudis about that
they plan to base them in in effect all
over the country but the very large bulk
of their force
they plan to base in the Northeast the
second largest amount of Tanks they plan
to base in the
of West they will also put some at their
armor training school in the North West
Southwest what are the Yemen in the area
of the Yemen's what is the Saudi Arabian
capability to deploy its armored force
outside its national boundaries of
virtually non-existent the why well the
Saudis do not have the sort of logistic
train that would be required for that
sort of long-range deployment it's not
easy even for the United States army to
move tanks long distances the Saudis do
not have never demonstrated a capability
of moving tanks great distances and
being able to support them in combat in
fact the Saudis have very little record
of combat at all so you're arguing would
be unless the tanks were pre positioned
on the border they would not have the
capacity the realistic capacity to use
those tanks beyond their borders that's
the argument they have given us they
will give us as part of the agreement if
we go ahead with this sale an assurance
that they will only use their tanks in
legitimate self-defense does that relate
to the location of the tanks no it
relates to the use of their tanks beyond
their borders so they would be able to
pre position the tanks along their
borders and be not in any way violating
the spirit of the agreement with the
United States relating to the sale of
those tanks that's right that's right
needed by equipment nor by training or
by doctrine do they have any power
projection capability well they don't
have this equipment so I think what mr.
Hughes was referring to was something I
was gonna mention as well you know we've
worked with the Saudi military for so
many years now and know them so well
it's simply in their exercises and their
training both in their schools
and out in the field they do not have
plans they do not exercise they do not
practice the kind of mobility that
you're talking about when you when you
recognize as mr. Clark said that even
countries like our own that practice
that on a on a rather frequent basis
have difficulties a country like Saudi
Arabia that doesn't is simply not going
to be able to pick up one morning and
and and thrust out in the way that you
suggest what is there any agreement with
the Saudis as to in the time of crisis
involving the United States that the
United States would have access to any
of this equipment we have not made it a
practice of putting that sort of request
in in writing or an agreement we do
however have a history of Saudi support
to look back on when the United States
did have to move military forces in a
hurry into the region during the reef
lagging of the Kuwaiti tankers and March
through August of 1987 we made a number
of requests to the Saudis for military
support all of which were affirmatively
responded to by the Saudi Arabian
government we've offered to enter into
the record on the classified basis a
summary of that Saudi military support
what
is there any prohibition relating the
sale regarding the Saudis ability to
transfer the use of any of this
equipment of these tanks to any other
nation so they're in the in the
agreement which we will sign if the sale
is approved there will be an explicit
prohibition against the Saudis
transferring the equipment to any other
nation without explicit US government
approval is that regard is that the ply
as well to US defense technologies in
the tank that it does we we already have
an agreement which is called a general
security of military information
agreement that and the specific sale
arrangement which they will sign
provides very good assurances and
enforceable verifiable assurances that
they will not transfer us classified
information or technology senator I
might add that we have great confidence
in that as well because the Saudi record
on that past sales has been excellent
what would your estimate be of the
combined strength of the tank forces of
the Arab states in the region B of all
Arab states or of Arab states in the
Persian Gulf in the Gulf the the Iraqi
armored force numbers in excess of 5,500
tanks they are by far the largest
armored force in the region the numbers
are outlined I think Senator in a fact
sheet which we've provided that
indicates that Iraq has an excess of
fifty five hundred tanks Yemen PDR why
has an excess of five
Iran has in excess of 700 the why AR has
an excess of 750 how sophisticated and
modern are the Iraqi tanks a very large
percentage of the Iraqi tank is the
Soviet t-72 and maybe I could ask
Colonel Eldridge who is an Armour expert
to describe the capabilities of that
tank it's a first line of Soviet tank
subsequently it has been replaced by the
t-80 and the Soviet group of Forces
Germany good tank 125 gun good fire
control system right now it can over
match anything the Saudis have with the
m1a2 that will not be the case give me a
degree of difference in terms of
superiority of the tank to the t-72
terms of numbers I would say in terms of
is it simply outclassed the tank um is
it not in the same category are they
rough lose or rough parity I have a
classified comparison of 14 factors that
I can provide you there are some factors
where the t-72 is superior there are
others where the a2 is superior on the
whole the a2 is markedly superior to the
t-72 how does the the total that you
just gave me mr. secretary 5500 500 and
750 Iraq the Yemen's and now would be
500 plus for the Saudis compared to the
total Israeli tank force
well the Israeli tank force is in excess
of 4,000
so it's almost the combined tank force
of Iraq Saudi Arabia Yemen should be
about twice that of the it's really a
senator that's true but I think it's
also somewhat irrelevant because the all
of those tanks would not combine to
threaten Israel number one number two
you can't in determining an armored
balance look only at the tanks on both
sides you also have to look at anti-tank
capabilities the US intelligence
community's judgment is that Israel
maintains a qualitative edge in the
armored anti-armor balance against any
likely array of Arab threat any likely
array and I assume the likely araid is
only takes into consideration Iraq it
takes into consideration the number of
countries in addition to Iraq it does is
that classified what countries I'm
citing a National Intelligence Estimate
so I'd rather not enumerate all of the
countries but I would be able to in a
classified response certainly certainly
submit that for the record I have more
questions that I see my colleague from
Maryland is here
you probably answered this but
realistically what defensive capability
does this afford the Saudi you you
you've indicated that that from
capability to disposition it has no
offensive capability is that correct it
we do not judge that the Saudis will
have an armored force projection
offensive capability
I assume that's the same as saying
offensive or what's the distinction for
a layman like me well I think if if
there were an attack inside Saudi Arabia
if an enemy were already inside Saudi
Arabia I think the Saudis could go on
the offensive and attack that force and
if the Saudis stationed those tanks at
to book or on the Jordanian border or on
the Israeli border they would not be
able to have that same capacity across
the border I think let's let's take for
example a stationing of tank set to book
they're already m60 tanks us provided
m60 tanks at the book which is where the
Saudis have their armored training
school from to book to Israel if the
concern is with the tanks pose an
offensive threat to Israel there is one
winding road through a series of long
mountain passes senator I firmly believe
that before the tanks got very far up
that road they would find it impossible
to get much further I don't think that
the Saudis the Israelis or any objective
military planner would think that tanks
station that the book could get to and
pose a military threat to Israel excuse
me there is of course no common Israel
Saudi border Jordan right between yes
but there now tell me about the terrain
across Jordan into Israel well from
Jordan and Israel the Train is
relatively flat we however would judge
that depending on where you are on the
Jordanian border of my my colleagues
correct me there are some places where
it's it's not good tank country but we
would judge that a movement of the of
the tanks to Jordan would not be in the
self defense of Saudi Arabia and would
be cause for us to be consulted under
the terms of the sale but a but a
movement of the tanks to the Jordanian
border at the area where the terrain is
flat well there that's that area does
not exist the Israeli Jordanian border
has some flat territory so there is so
there is no is it realistic for the
Israelis to be able to quickly and
effectively make it as a practical
matter impractical for the Saudis to be
able to transit Jordan from the
Jordanian Saudi border there's no crisis
there is no good tank country on the
saudi jordanian border we we believe
that the israelis could with a minimum
amount of force stop any movement of
tanks from Saudi Arabia against Israel
but we don't think that's a likely
scenario senator I know we we usually
don't think those things and I believe I
understand why we don't think that MA
maybe I've been here too long I remember
when we didn't think there'd be a
six-day war I remember when we didn't
think other things we matter of fact we
we almost guaranteed it wouldn't happen
and couldn't happen and but it did but
so I'm not suggesting this is
necessarily in the same category I'm
asking genuine questions of inquiry that
I don't know the answers to
so I've driven that Road from the the
Saudi Jordanian check pointing back to
Aqaba which is
as you well know right next to a lot if
it winds on
so that there is a a quite nice
four-lane highway but but it is a very
narrow sort of piece of land on which
one would have to move a fairly
substantial force not to mention
logistics backup and and the whole point
I think we were trying to make to you is
that the terrain between Toughbook and
the Gulf of Aqaba is a mountain range a
very severe one which runs entire of the
entire East Side ours have to stop and
think east side of the Rift Valley it's
it's quite a difficult piece of terrain
to traverse and it's through that
terrain where there really is only one
road all the logistics support for any
tank that ever got through would still
have to come through the same pass and
it's just I think we could have answered
your your answer there quite
categorically no colonel is a military
man you're an Israeli you don't worry at
all about these tanks being in Saudi
Arabia there's no contingency planning
you have to do that's of any consequence
the fact that now they exist if I were
in is really tank officer I would
coordinate with my airforce counterpart
for targeting and acquisition and put it
in the plan so there was heard we've
heard Israeli threat briefings over the
years classified Israeli threat
briefings we work closely with them on
their analysis of the threat and how to
counter it I have never heard and
there's early a military planner or an
Israeli military intelligence officer
even mention the threat from that
direction a threat from the Saudi
armored force a threat from the Saudi
ground force I assume in part that could
be because the nature of the threat is
not what is about to be I don't think
that's the reason either okay that's why
I'm asking the questions so so as as an
Israeli military planner this is not
something you have to worry about that's
right that right colonel you're the guy
the tank man I'm looking at you not the
rest of these guys it is not something I
would be concerned about but as in any
plan I would make sure there were plans
in place to close that road which could
be done very easily okay
last question mr. secretary you've
indicated in your testimony that the
Saudis have cooperated in trying to
achieve a Middle East peace plan what
contribution have they made toward the
resolution of the situation on the West
Bank in Gaza you're talking about the
current situation surfing any well I
think that'll for now
I think sir that a number of times over
the last several months we have in fact
had discussions with the Saudis about
the variety of proposals that a number
of governments Egypt and Israel have put
forward and we have found the Saudis
supportive willing to encourage other
players who had hoped that perhaps to
and what way are they supportive sir
they are supportive in going to those
Palestinian elements urging them to
remain engaged in the negotiations
urging them not to reject proposals that
they might otherwise consider
unacceptable on the grounds that a
negotiating process was the real route
to to a peace settlement and this is
something that we valued it is something
that we have repeatedly used and support
of our own efforts and intend to do so
again what has been their public
position with regard to the u.s.
position on the West Bank in terms of
future settlement no no no no in terms
of how to resolve the conflict in those
two areas the Saudis want the conflict
in those two areas resolved peacefully
through negotiations between Israelis
support elections they have supported
continuation of the talks based on the
proposals that are before us from both
the Israelis and and I don't think
that's the that's the answer the
question the question is do they support
elections and if so under what
conditions on the West Bank the the
Saudis have supported the participation
of the Palestinians and elections is one
of the ways in which Palestinians can
participate
they have said as many other Arab
governments have said that elections
should not be the the endgame they are
looking for a comprehensive settlement
that will resolve the entire issue how
does their position differ from the
Egyptians well the Egyptians are trying
to facilitate a process and they have
been very careful to try to avoid
speaking for say Palestinians or others
and in that regard the Saudis have tried
to do much the same thing
the Saudis will tell you when you ask
them that we're not we do not consider
ourselves a confrontation State we are
not involved in the same way as those
states immediately around Israel and the
Palestinians and so they try to avoid
public I didn't mean to interrupt but I
just want to say that a business meeting
is scheduled 11 o'clock and I would ask
the prm's to notify their Senators that
we really want to have have all hands
here by 10:30 11:30 and actually really
this your hearing will wind up at that
time so let's shoot for 11:30 sorry
it's miss my last question to follow up
they they do not view themselves a
confrontational state do they still view
themselves as the font of financial
support state no most other people in
the region view them as the financial
support but they they have used their
their financial resources in an effort
to influence other governments in the
direction yes that's not very nice way
of saying it has there been any due
munition and the support for the PLO
financially in the last three years no
the the Saudis continue to support the
PLO I got asked an earlier question that
was a bit more specific than I had data
on today which related to its budget but
no they do consider it continue
supporting it financially but I would
tell you that we consider their support
for the moderate Palestinian elements
helpful right you don't consider the PLO
the modest the moderate the moderate
Palestinian effort do I think we
recognize that within the Palestinian
community there a variety of
personalities political
and political viewpoints that the PLO is
not one of those that is moderate is it
a near viewer is it the administration's
view we have a dialogue with them and
then efforts are tried to influence
their attitude on the entire process
you're doing very well but you're not
answering my question
I don't I think when we use the word
radical we've invariably applied that to
a number of other groups like the ano
that pflp-gc and other Palestinian
groups that have been very remained very
active in in areas of terrorism and in
the use of the force against civilian
targets so I I don't consider the the
organization that we're talking with in
that same category no sir no further
questions Thank You senator just to come
back to you the earlier line of the
discussion regarding the location of
Saudi forces and intention I just like
to point out that Saudi Arabia has never
paid played any significant or
consequential role in any of the
arab-israeli laws I understand that they
or they have played a significant role a
bank significant bank role they have
played in the past and no I don't think
once you say that in the context of the
war of the conflict itself no you don't
really just very quickly mr. Clark
senator Biden may have asked this I'm
curious to know what other arms sales
are in the offing to Saudi Arabia so
there we have no plans for any other
notifications to Congress this year for
ourselves to Saudi Arabia as to next
year we do not have any agreements with
the Saudis for any we will tell you in
the Javits Report which is doing on the
30th of January what we know then but
right now we don't know of any sale to
Saudi Arabia that will that is already
well advanced in negotiation
let me let me try to refine that a bit
if I can do you have any plans in the
offing for any major arms sales to Saudi
Arabia next year well so there I assume
you're concerned as with previous
questions is with f5 replacement sale
that's been much discussed in the in the
press let me tell you that on the f5
replacement sale we have not started any
real discussions with the Saudis or any
real negotiations with them about that
sale you have any understandings we have
no understandings with them about the f5
replacement sale we do not know when
they plan to make that decision as to
which aircraft they want if we know more
I don't know very much now if we know
more in by the time we submit the javis
report we'll provide that have you
indicated to the Saudis that you're
prepared to act favorably on a decision
on their part with respect to aircraft
no well how are they in the process of
trying to decide which aircraft they
want if you haven't made such an
indication well Senator the way it works
is that the Saudis as with this tank
sale look at the range of possible
alternatives when they decide which one
they want they come to us and they ask
can we have this one they need to look
at French aircraft and the European
fighter aircraft they then make a
decision as to which one they want and
they come and ask they haven't made a
decision that as far as the United
States government knows as to when
they're going to replace the f5 let
alone with what so we have had no
understanding with them we have made no
commitment this is not very far advanced
Senator Dodd you wonder as you have it
fine senator Simon it just one question
for secretary Clark I saw the New York
Times piece about China possibly selling
medium-range missiles and among others
to to Syria
first of all just in general I think we
have not been as firm and forthright on
the Chinese question as I think we
should be that the an if I can just use
as one example when the Chinese student
leaders were here there was no official
from the State Department who met with
the Chinese student leaders who had led
this courageous move in China and I was
when I inquired about it I was told it
was considered inappropriate for a US
official to meet with them I think to
the contrary anyway I am concerned about
the proliferation of missiles I think
any one has to be concerned and I'm
particularly concerned as we put more
and more missiles into the Middle East
situation any comments mr. secretary
yes senator as we as we discussed two
weeks ago in this committee the United
States has entered into a number of
efforts to stop missile proliferation we
have had very high-level discussions
with the Chinese on this issue and we've
received assurances which we've outlined
to you in closed session we think we
have made it extraordinarily clear to
the Chinese that we will take a very
very dim view of any sales of ballistic
missiles particularly to this region let
me ask you this are we involved in
missile technology transfer to the
Chinese absolutely not
I I have no further questions mr.
chairman you're about ready to break
senator senses well let me ask mr. Clark
a couple of questions if you've already
answered these I regret I couldn't be
here beginning a simply say so and I'll
read it in the record and not cause you
to repeat it have you talked about the
the Saudi participation and the effort
to deny Israel's credentials to the UN
yes so there we are all right
now I understood you to say that they
are making an evaluation of what type of
aircraft they want did they make an
evaluation of what kind of tank they
wanted yes senator they looked at a
range of European and other tax before
deciding they wanted this time if we
declined to sell them this tank of what
would they do well they have a number of
other choices if I were they I would
choose the British challenger 2 tank
point is that if we don't approve the
sale and make the sale that will not
deny them tanks so there's no doubt that
they will acquire a very modern and
sophisticated tank
have you talked about any possible
chemical of biological warfare weapons
that the Saudis might be considering out
looking at yes senator we have
assurances from the highest levels of
the Saudi government that they are not
interested and have no capability now
nor are they trying to acquire chemical
or biological weapons thank you very
much and I would ask that the record be
kept open for questions that may be I
was invited by colleagues I thank
secretary claw garage ticket one
question and now file the rest of my
questions in writing mr. clerk on
October 31 do you recall telling the
committee quote we have had dialogue
with China the Soviet Union Argentina
Egypt and Sweden to name a few and have
received satisfaction that they are now
conforming to export control guidelines
which we find satisfactory you call that
safe yes sir
is that still your opinion it is ten
days later on November the ninth the New
York Times printed a story quoting and
arms control and disarmament agency
official expressing grave concern that
China may drop its commitment not to
sell medium-range missiles and
technology to Middle Eastern countries
is act they're wrong about that well I
don't know that that was an actor
statement sir but I will I will say that
as far as the United States government
knows right now the Chinese are abiding
by their assurances given to us now
there are reports from time to time that
the Chinese are trying to market
missiles in the Middle East we continue
to receive those reports if we ever we
have not yet seen conclusive evidence
that they have done so we have not seen
evidence that they have violated their
assurances to us we are again making the
point very strongly to them that we
would take an extraordinarily dim view
of any Chinese ballistic missile sail to
the Middle East well you said if we ever
then you stopped and backed up what were
you going to say afterwards if we ever
if we ever got evidence hard evidence
that a sail was about to occur we would
make it clear again at a very very high
level that we believe we have assurances
from them and we would not want those
assurances violated the Chinese have
made the mistake in the past and
exporting ballistic missiles to the
Middle East we think that is an
extraordinarily destabilizing factor in
the Middle East after they made that
mistake we had a number of discussions
with them we think they will not do it
again based on those discussions and it
would be a grave error I think on the
part of the Chinese if they proceeded
with a missile sale I think it would be
extraordinarily
to us-chinese relations if after our
discussions that we've had that they
changed their mind and went ahead with a
sale in the Middle East so you don't
think they are negotiating right now at
this moment to sell missiles to the
Middle East you don't think they are as
I said some there from time to time we
see reports that representatives of
Chinese companies are in the Middle East
marketing this or that we do not have
any conclusive evidence that they have
done anything that's contrary to our the
assurances they gave us what I have
which I'll pay you probably have already
seen them undoubtedly have already seen
them but I have for unclassified report
stating flatly that on May the 18th the
Chinese signed an agreement with the
Syrians to provide m9 missiles are you
familiar with those report I haven't
seen any unclassified reports that
they've signed the contract I think it
would be a grave mistake if the Chinese
tried to export the m9 to Syria well I
will have further questions I will not
take up the time but I want you to be
very careful about any declaration that
you know of no activity about the
Chinese going on I know of a lot of
activity and a lot of reports about
marketing I have no conclusive evidence
that they have decided to go ahead with
a sale and we are making it clear we've
made it clear in the past we're making
it clear again we believe that would be
a grave mistake that would seriously
damage us-chinese relations to what
extent to a great extent all of those a
qualitative aren't they well I won't
push you on the thing but you better be
careful about sending there I don't I
don't think there is any distance
they're not doing this because there are
reports reliable reports to the contrary
well some there I don't think there is
any distance between your position and
the position of the administration on
what the effect would be if China tried
to sell for example the m9 to Syria both
you and the administration think that
would be an extraordinary mistake on the
part of the Chinese that would damage us
Chinese we're
patience our guarantees to the length of
my cable - it will be an extraordinary
mistake on their part whatever I can do
we agree senator yeah thank you very
much I'd like to move ahead with a
business meeting if that's agreeable to
dr. De Luca the contact you very much
you excu